americans are being devastated by the
coronavirus at levels once considered
unthinkable
more than 187 000 new cases were
reported yesterday and that
is a new record we're also seeing
increased deaths
more than 2 000 people just yesterday
that's the number that the experts had
warned we would hit by christmas
the coronavirus task force held its
first public briefing yesterday
in months it came as the cdc issued a
blunt new warning
telling americans not to travel for
thanksgiving
our lead national correspondent david
begno joins us with some breaking
vaccine news david good morning
good morning we just heard from pfizer
they will today
request emergency use authorization from
the fda
now we don't know how long it's going to
take to get the authorization
so that the vaccine can start being
distributed to elderly people
frontline workers and eventually to the
rest of us but again that could take
months this morning we are on 57th
street in midtown manhattan look at the
line to get tested it stretches around
the block
i counted it 98 people when i started
counting
and that was about 10 minutes ago some
folks were lining up at 5 00 a.m you
mentioned the covet task force
it's been months since we heard from
them and finally they took to the podium
yesterday
let's start with that this is really a
call to action for briefing the country
for the first time in four months
white house coronavirus task force
coordinator dr debra burks
acknowledged that the situation
nationally is worse than ever
this is more cases more rapidly than
what we had seen before
but the news is not all bad with
emergency use
authorizations or euas as they're known
for vaccines on the horizon officials
say distribution
could start within weeks eua comes 24
hours later vaccines will be distributed
dr anthony fauci called the results of
coronavirus vaccine trials
extraordinary and he urged all americans
to get vaccinated
as soon as possible the process of the
speed
did not compromise at all safety nor did
it compromise
scientific integrity dr fauci also said
right now
more than ever before americans should
double down on hand washing mask wearing
and social distancing if you're fighting
a battle
and the cavalry is on the way you don't
stop shooting
meanwhile the fight continues in icus
across america
where nurses are battling not just the
virus but denial
registered nurse ashley bartholomew says
she was shocked
when one of her covet patients in an el
paso hospital told her this
it just kind of you know gestured
towards the tv like well fake news
it doesn't really seem like it's more
than a flu i said to him
i have never seen so much death
and so much sickness in the past two
weeks
than i have in my entire 10 years in
healthcare combined
bartholomew says she cried in front of
him and she says
after that patient left the icu his
perspective changed
he said wow i i saw
the other people and i was wrong
what did that moment mean to you when he
seemed to get it
i would love to say that it felt like a
victory but the big picture
that if there are people
that are thinking along these same lines
we're in trouble what was your intention
behind sharing this
i don't know i haven't been asked that i
mean i guess my intention
is just that
you know misinformation is killing us
i can tell you from traveling this
country for the last seven months
covering coronavirus
the denial is real and gail it is
affecting
it is affecting as you just saw from
that nurse the front-line workers who
are taking care of people who are dying
that's why david i think it's so
important that you're telling these
stories but you know what really hurts
me is that it has to get this dire
for people to get it we keep hearing
these stories over and over it has to
get
almost where you're near the brink where
people say yeah this is really serious
later and they're still fighting again i
know i know i yeah we just have to keep
telling the story david thank you thank
you very much
and the next test of trust of course
will be the vaccine exactly i want to
underscore the doctor anthony fauci says
this thing is solid yeah they have not
hopefully hear him say that
it is helpful to say that